make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so originally I was not gonna cover
this at least not right now right like
the most anticipated comic book movie
and I would argue the most anticipated
movie of all time is coming out like
tonight why would I talk about anything
but in games that kind of baffled me
right like in games coming out it's like
yeah Rob I know in games coming out and
it's the one thing that everybody's
talking about can you talk about spawn
and it was like no absolutely not but
there but then like I read heroes a
crisis 8 and I was like oh my god like I
have to cover this because do here's the
thing man do Tom King alright those guys
who don't like Tom King you're wrong and
I'm gonna tell you why you're wrong so
this whole thing was like a giant
mystery right like we didn't know who
actually killed everybody at sanctuary
and heroes in crisis but at least not in
the beginning but then it was revealed
that it was Harley Quinn but then it was
also revealed that it was Booster Gold
and the question was well then who was
it that did it right because if we saw
Harley Quinn kill everyone in the
beginning and then we saw Booster Gold
kill everyone
then who actually killed everyone it was
a great big huge mystery so what this
does is it basically picks up with like
Wally West and it's the coolest thing
because what he basically says is like
this is my confession and I was just
like wow like right out of the gate like
it's dudas it's it's nuts like I'm I'm I
am dick you see this is why I like slow
builds right like a lot of people out
there don't really like slow bills they
like like I want the stories hold on
three issues or less which doesn't give
you enough time to really build anything
up but slow builds are awesome because
the payoff is usually worth it and like
this is one of those instances where it
was definitely worth it because when you
go through this he start like like
literally Wally starts talking about how
like keep in there at sanctuary for a
few weeks you know and he was there to
recover and all that kind of cool stuff
but the funny thing about this is he
starts to talk about how he looked at
himself in relation to everybody else
and it's one of the things that we
weren't initially made aware of what
what Wally basically says here is that
with the nature of sanctuary being what
it was that all these different people
were there to basically cope with the
struggles of they didn't do it now we
knew that right like we knew the basis
behind sanctuary was that it was
supposed to be a place of healing and
maybe your method of healing was just
punching you know virtual reality drones
and maybe your method of healing was
just meditation whatever the case was
all these different heroes and even some
of the villains to a degree who were
trying to reform we're going through
sanctuary for the purpose of healing
himself sort of healing their minds
healing their their spirits and so on
and so forth so they could go forward
having dealt with all this trauma but
for the most part what we weren't really
told and what really seems to be hit on
the head here is that they were all in
isolation at his kind of interest
because tonch inks would have made that
ambiguous right like all we really saw
with regards to the various characters
and heroes in crisis is like what they
were doing to heal we didn't see what
they were doing in their downtime we
didn't know if they were all like just
kind of hanging out and mingling and
talking and it sort of socializing was
kind of that kind of the the healing
method which would have made sense
because if you were poison ivy and you
were trying to like get to a better
version of yourself then what better way
to do that than to spend time hanging
out with heroes people who normally go
through and save others but in fact all
these individuals were in a
compartmentalized space so they were
basically all isolated from one another
now again that allowed for anonymity it
allowed for them to be able to basically
function without anybody knowing what
their confessions were or what they were
doing to heal which provided a lot more
privacy and it basically allowed them to
operate with impunity in a small space
without any real consequence for what it
was that they were doing but when when
Wally started looking at this and when
he started started kind of focusing on
himself the conclusion that he came to
was that he was crazy but the issue here
was that when he looked at sanctuary it
wasn't a place where like all these
people were going to heal in the mind of
Wally West it was all just a front like
literally everything going on in
sanctuary was designed for the purpose
of making him feel like he wasn't that
bad and so what this means is that for
the most part when he looks at all the
other people they're basically actors
that they're there just to basically put
on the show and make it all seem legit
and so he started ask these questions
why is it anonymous why is it that that
nobody really knows what anybody else is
doing
and he essentially disordered like feed
into his own ideology right and that's
kind of the cool thing here that's one
of the things that um King hits on right
like for whatever reason we will develop
an ideology right and then where the
thought process used to be you know in a
previous age of humanity where the
thought process used to be here is an
opinion I have let me find facts that
either you know confirm this opinion or
conflict with this opinion and if the
facts that I find conflict with my
opinion then maybe it's time for me to
reorganize my opinion in this day and
age it's I have an opinion now let me
find the facts to support it and ignore
the facts that don't and that's exactly
what happened with Wally Wally started
going through and he develop this
ideology he's crazy so then he started
going through and looking at all the
information and we either twist it and
skew it or would ignore it if it didn't
support his perception and he would
basically say like this is all the
information that shows and I'm a crazy
person this is all the information that
shows that like all these things are
messed up and what he really kind of
says here is that in his mind that maybe
some of it had to do with Linda Park and
the reason why is he says like for the
most part he was isolated and alone and
that's the interesting thing about this
because
look at wall-e here while he does do
something pretty screwed up in a lot of
way she's a victim because when you look
at wall-e post DC rebirth for the most
part aside from the Titans
there was nobody really there to kind of
guide him and how to interact with with
Linda Barry did to a degree but the
problem is that Barry was he really took
kind of a cowardly wrong right it's like
hey Wally you should go and talk to
Linda and what his response was no I
don't want to in the Barry said okay and
then walked away
what Wally needed was to have his hand
forced what all he needed was to be made
to go talk to Linda Park because Wally
didn't know that's what he needed and
that's that that's something that Barry
should have been able to pick up on
because Barry was his mentor and so
following this we see one of the coolest
set of events unfold in the history of
Wally West character so so what Wally
ends up doing is he basically sits down
and he says okay I have to find out
whether or not this is a show or not I
have to find out whether or not any of
this is real but the problem with
sanctuary according to Wally is that all
the confessions that are made are
literally split into like a billion
different pieces they're drag minted all
over the place and then just kind of
scattered out into you wherever it is
that they happen to go but Wally is the
fastest man alive
and so while he's like okay well I'm
just gonna grab all the pieces and they
grab all these little digital bytes and
bring them back together again and
that's what he did
Wally West was the one who recompiled
everybody's confessions he's the one
that basically brought it all back
together and then he watched all the
confessions and the issue is that when
he did that it broke him because he was
literally watching nothing but pain and
suffering for however long it took him
to watch and it basically warped and
screwed up his mind and the result was
that he had it has simply kind of broke
him on a mental level now following this
he basically races out of the house to
catch his breath and then what he does
is he talks about the Speed Force and he
says that with the Speed Force people
look at it and they say yeah the Speed
Force is so cool he's got an accelerated
healing factor you can time-travel you
can travel to other dimensions if you
vibrate the right way you can do all
kinds of really awesome things but Wally
says it like there's a huge drawback and
a huge drawback is that you're
essentially taking your portion of a
multiversal source of energy and keeping
it confined into yourself and if it were
to explode out of you what would happen
and that's what happens here that when
Wally's trying to regain his composure
when he's watching all this pain and
suffering replay in his head when he
triggers an alarm by messing with the
computer systems and everybody comes
filing out all this energy does kind of
lets loose he snaps for a brief second
and when that happens all these people
in sanctuary are killed and so the
question is what does Wally do because
he just basically killed everyone
what is Wally do after this he
constructs a plan he basically frames
Booster Gold and Harley Quinn what he
essentially does is that because booster
and Holly were the last two who were in
there they last two who left that what
he essentially did is he messed with
their VR systems so that when they
thought they were leaving they were
actually walking back into the VR system
itself and then he he interned modified
sanctuary so that Harley Quinn saw
Booster Gold kill everybody including
Wally West and Booster Gold saw Harley
Quinn kill everybody including Wally
West and so following that he ran five
days into the future like after they
were done he ran five days into the
future brought himself back and and
literally had this conversation he
placed a fake body basically like he
engineered an entire crime scene and he
did this because he was with Barry Allen
for decades right for like at least
twenty years of his life he knows
exactly how Barry Allen thinks and with
Barry Allen being the CSI the crime
scene investigator that the Justice
League would inevitably call in the best
one in the world he knew exactly what
Barry would look for any knew exactly
what Barry would miss he also knew what
Batman would follow up with because
remember flash has been on T or a Wally
West has been on teams of Batman before
and said well he well he's not the best
person to know exactly how Batman thinks
what he does know is how Batman
functions as a detective Wally West
tricked Barry Allen and tricked Batman
into believing that he actually died and
then what he did is he used like he
basically set up frames he killed
everyone and lied about it and so
following that like he basically said
like I had five days you know I had five
days to sit down and to create this
confession Wally West killed everyone
faked a crime scene tampered with
evidence framed Harley Quinn and Booster
Gold all for the purpose of trying to
find a way to basically escape a murder
that he made and try to find a way to do
something right to make up for what it
was that he did wrong and the only
conclusion he could come to you the only
thing that he could figure out the only
thing he believed he could do right in
order to correct what it was that he did
wrong was to confess to send this
confession directly to Lois Lane and
it's crazy because what this basically
means now is that like Wally West is a
murderer now given the circumstance in
terms of how it unfolded one of the
things that you guys will always usually
always notice when it comes to
superheroes in in various color book
superheroes and Marvel superheroes in DC
is they usually get a pass right like
that was one of the best lines of secret
Empire the kind of sidetrack here from
from heroes in crisis that was one of
the best parts of secret empire when
Steve when evil Captain America was
talking to good Captain America that
literally what what evil Captain America
said was like hey like I'm not one of
your Avenger friends right like I'm not
Thor I'm not the Incredible Hulk I don't
get a pass it's one of these things were
like oh and I'm having it anytime for
what I did with Wally
something akin to that right like wall-e
is a hero and so the result is that
he'll be given the benefit of the doubt
if this was any other villain out there
immediately he would've been put on
trial probably sent to our commerce into
some other prison Bellerive thrown into
the suicide squad like who knows what
would have happened to them but they
certainly would not get the benefit of
the doubt right like if the Joker had
done this or if like Harley Quinn had
done this like they would have
immediately been thrown in there but
with Wally it's like well but I mean
he's a good guy though so like we got to
give him the benefit of the doubt I mean
sure he did a really bad thing but like
we like him though so like it's okay
like that's that's literally what it'll
turn into and it's so intriguing because
it basically kind of throws into the
idea of like what happens to Wally next
where do we go from here Wally is a
confessed killer he confessed to his
crime what follows after this one of the
best comics I've read in a long time I
love heroes in crisis it's absolutely
amazing that being said guys we're gonna
read this video to an end if you are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace